i'd like to thank lab groups for the
opportunity
to give this presentation so my name is
dr gary prokop
i'm the clinical virologist at cleveland
clinic
and uh a staff microbiologist
and the topic today is testing for sars
kobe 2 and i wanted to share our
experience
so i have no disclosures and
our objectives are as follows i like to
describe the optimal uses of the various
types
of stars cov2 tests we'll touch a little
bit not a lot on angin
antibody and we'll we'll touch a little
deeper on
different nucleic acid tests discuss uh
the molecular
detector of surge cov2 during
convalescence
a pretty important topic we're going to
discuss the impact
of using a test with high specificity
something we all want
in the diagnostic versus screening
setting we're also going to
review the benefits and limitations of
alternate
specimen types like saliva that's become
very popular
and alternate testing strategies like
pooling which has a lot of questions
around it
so uh let's get started i'm not going to
spend a lot of time on things you
already know uh
you know a good bit already about the
sars
coronavirus these viruses infect animals
and humans
and of course as we all know
unfortunately
can can jump species and
become embedded in our species
so what do you do when you're asked to
test for a virus that you've never met
and leadership wants it done yesterday
well
as you know uh the government has a
process called emergency used
authorization
and how this unroll on unrolled in the
united states is at first this was
limited to
testing for for this virus was limited
public health facilities
it became readily apparent that the
public health infrastructure was
going to be bowled over by this and and
they indeed were
and so the emergency use authorization
was
opened to others and that includes
diagnostic vendors to
make and distribute tests commercial
reference laboratories
as well as academic institutions and
other hospitals
i became immediately aware that
um the laboratory infrastructure
we we've been saying for years needs to
be buoyed up
as well as a public health
infrastructure and those are areas for
uh future discussions um so
first of all not all tests are created
equal and this has become
apparent as we've rolled out these
different assays
and so we decided at the clinic to bring
up
the cdc assay um what do i know about
stars kobe 2 right
and so we we really have a choice
between that and the who assay we
we chose the cdc assay and immediately
clinicians were asking what's the
sensitivity and specificity
and this was before there were any cases
of cyrus kobe 2 in ohio
i had to tell them i don't know these
clinical studies have really not been
performed
so it's not an fda submission trial it's
an emergency use
release right and so what is in the
fda emergency youth criteria and there
are a number of things and you can find
this on their website
and what i'd say is i think it's a good
start
they have good things like in silico
cross reactivity
analysis that you need to do in order to
demonstrate that your primers and probes
will not cross react with other viruses
and or other microorganisms or human
genetic targets etc
they make you do things like determine a
limited detection but then
falls a little bit short they don't say
which limits of detection are acceptable
or not acceptable so
i like to think that the fda eua is a
great place to start
um and and eua's are usually pretty
limited in time you think about how
long did we use these for ebola not very
long
but we've been using these now for
months and months so i think there's
opportunities for
eua plus after a uh
after an assay has been in operation for
quite a while
and those are again additional things to
consider
so what we did was we ended up doing a
five test comparison
and this has uh just been accepted for
publication in american journal economic
pathology so
hopefully you can find it there very
soon if if not when you're hearing this
this talk and essentially what we did
was
we had brought up stars kobe 2 we
brought up the
tib mobile assay and the roche z480
brought up the um the expert express
from cepheid for our rapid assay
brought up another rapid assay the uh
the simplex from diocerin and we're in
the process of bringing up the id now
during that during that uh early
assessment of the id now
we had a number of misses that made us
do this study
uh what we did with this study was we
actually said
uh we defined a specimen as truly
containing the virus
if any one of these tests were positive
and that positive could be corroborated
by any
other test so you needed at least two
tests to be positive to call that
specimen positive
single positive will be called false
positive and
uh from this definition you could
determine true positive true negative
false positive false negative reactions
and determine your sensitivity and
specificity
and during this time we are most
concerned about false negative rates
because we were talking about which
tests could we use to put patients into
the hospital
and we did not want to be putting people
onto a fault onto a coven negative
award that i had the assay hadn't missed
so you can see here the top three uh
the top three assays had
very high sensitivity and specificity
they really all had high specificity
but the two assays simplex and id now
had lower sensitivities
and so we're going to come back and
explain why a little bit later
but those are our initial findings and
we'll leave it there for now so what was
our experience on how to deal with a
pandemic
and you can see dr reddy's
paper listed at the bottom and she
basically has
uh written up uh with myself and other
colleagues
how we handled um operationalizing
uh coven 19 testing at the clinic and
i have to say this has been a great
experience our chief of
uh medical uh operations dr bob wiley
runs incident command
and you know has a tight ship i'll say
and i and a lot of great lieutenants
and so um this team would
meet we sometimes met twice daily early
on
we would run tabletop exercises of what
were
worst case scenarios all aspects of
operations at the clinic were present
we would report out on current state
we'd have
projects tasks we'd go and work on those
come back and report
later on so this very organized
systems-based
practice approach was really key to to
for us to address
uh coven 19 testing early on
a little bit more um what exactly is
going on how many tests
are we doing and this is where our
informatics team was absolutely
key and so they were able to build
dashboard after dashboard i can't tell
you how many dashboards we have right
now i've really lost track
you know as far as you know outpatient
inpatient stat testing etc
but the point here is your informatics
team is absolutely key
and they sure have been great partners
test utilization something i spent a lot
of time in and
dr reddy and hendrix are running that
show now here
but uh what we've really had to do
is we had limited allocations of
everything just like i'm sure you did
and so we had to decide how are we going
to utilize
um rapid the the limited rapid tests
that we have the cepheids for example
how are we going to utilize the limited
routine tests
i think we all saw from from the
beginning if you just open the doors
you know you're going to be overwhelmed
with testing and so
we really put in guard rails around
these tests again with everyone at the
table
and the conversation that if we just
open the doors you're not going to have
tests for the patients that need it the
most
so this team-based approach was really a
great way
to approach limited allocations
and again there were home monitoring
programs for those patients that
were able to go home either after
testing or after discharge
all through my chart and again teamed up
with medical informatics making this
absolutely key so
at the beginning we were using a test
based strategy to bring health care
workers back to work
and that turn that that proved to be
pretty problematic
because we couldn't get health care
workers back um
they had recovered from coven 19 and we
were
requiring two negative tests to come
back to work and we couldn't get two
negative tests it does negative one day
positive the next etcetera and what we
have learned of course and
i'm sure you know this too this coven 19
has a long tail
and in that tale of convalescence there
are
what is believed to be and uh we believe
to be
uh shedding of non-infectious viral
fragments viral particles
um that will be positive in the pcr test
and that was really hamstringing us to
bring folks back to work
but we needed data to move to a
non-test-based strategy
when we started to study this you could
see that
the viral load became much lower
as you move uh from left to right along
the x-axis
the viral load becomes much lower
as the days away from initial symptoms
proceeds
so this is not surprising
uh but those are the uh folks that we
were
we were catching in this long tale of
convalescence so dr
sharesta and that paper is
i believe it's going to be referenced in
an upcoming slide if not
seen clinical infectious diseases
utilize
the uh the ct values the crossing
threshold values
uh to determine viral loads based on our
lower limit of detection and
from this you could see that you know
after
about 14 days you had such a substantial
drop in the median viral load over 32
000
fold that we were convinced
this was in addition to other data that
was in the literature
that this would be a fine time to bring
people back to work and so we
use this data to move from a test base
to a non-test based strategy
and i i know as you do ct values have
been
used as a surrogate for really an
official viral load or a
quantitative viral load in this pandemic
so what are we detecting i've already
alluded to it and
you can see the uh paper from nature
medicine demonstrating this long tail as
well as a
uh repeated dr shrestha and there is the
reference
and there is good evidence that we are
detecting non-infectious virus
viral fragments what is that evidence
there's a nice paper out of south korea
that demonstrates that these folks
when they go home don't infect their
family members
and as you know if you have sargeras
kobe 2 in in an
active disease state your family members
are at risk
at heightened risk um so that
that support so these aren't these folks
are not infectious
and then also uh this paper from germany
as well as
others demonstrate that you can't
culture the virus from these patients
so so it's probably a um
again viral particles or fragments that
are non-replicative
so let's go back to our five test
comparison
and what we did was we looked at our
patient populations thanks to dr
harrington
our senior author on this one uh who who
wanted to do this
and uh they reviewed the charts
and you can see the the folks that we
were missing
in the diocerin and in the abbott
assay were folks that had lower viral
loads
and both of these assays omit a
nucleic acid extraction step and
uh that is what we believe is the reason
and
you know this is pretty there's a lot of
supportive evidence of course and we've
generated some of it
uh in in the molecular biology
literature that
clear sensitivity will increase of
course if you have a
high quality nucleic acid extract to
start the amplification process
so we believe that that's what we were
we were missing whether it's clinically
relevant or not is another question
but that is an explanation for uh the
limited sensitivity the moderate
sensitivity
of those two assays so let's
be i'll be relatively brief on antigen
and antibody testing
antigen testing is attractive because
it's
inexpensive quick the issue is
it's less sensitive but equally specific
and we have a long history in
microbiology of
knowing about antigen testing and
studying antigen testing
and for infectious agents from group
based drop to years of studying
influenza
and response and social virus
antigen detection tests and so
in symptomatic patients if this test is
positive
you have a high positive predictive
value you don't need to follow it up
with a molecular test
or with a confirmatory test which
usually is a molecular in this case
but if the test is negative you will
need to follow it up with a
molecular test in a symptomatic person
the a a a different issue
occurs when you're looking at
asymptomatic populations and it's not
limited just to
antigen detection tests but it's the
production of
more uh faults a higher percentage of
false positives
in this setting and we're going to we're
going to take a deep dive in that in
just a little bit
antibody tests you saw there and the
antibody test just flooded the market at
the beginning
there's great evidence that antibody
testing
should not be used for diagnosis there
are very limited instances where i've
heard good
arguments to use it the immunologists
that i know
have uh readily convinced me these are
are not useful they're both
false positives due to cross reactivity
with other coronaviruses and other
substances
there's no evidence of course that this
um
that positive tests are makes a person
immune these are useful of course for
public health surveillance
and we have cdc
quotations here for the antigen test it
may be necessary to confirm a rapid
antigen test
with a nucleic acid test especially if
the result is
inconsistent with the clinical context
so they look sick and it's negative you
got to confirm it
if they look well and it's positive you
need to confirm it antibody tests
the food and drug administration has not
authorized antibody testing to diagnose
cobit 19 and cdc does not currently
recommend using antibody testing
for diagnosis of any infection so
there you have it antigen and antibody
test and
again we'll take some deep dives on the
issues of false positives and
asymptomatics in just a few
okay so uh we we started out with
it's all about testing and we've heard
anybody who wants a test can have a test
this is not a good approach um
this is what happens when you do that
it is really testing without a plan why
would we ever do this this is not a good
approach
so grab a test any test serology a less
expense
a sensitive molecular a more sensitive
molecule how about antigens that quick
cheap i want those this is not the
appropriate approach either
let's think this through this is not our
first
rodeo in path and lab medicine so let's
go back to what's tried and true
and implement those principles here it's
all about
using the right test in the right
patient care setting
with an understanding of how
the test performance characteristics and
the prevalence of disease affect the
positive and negative
predictive value again this is where
we're going to deep dive this is the way
to go
so why these false positives we saw this
rash of false positives
in vermont and we have a great uh
quote from our governor ohio governor
and i have to say mike dewine it really
did a great has done a great job with
our pandemic hats off to him
ohio governor says his false positive is
a wake-up call
about newer types of coronavirus tests
so this is a non-uh
non-medical person saying this come on
we need to
employ what's tried and true okay
so what happened here how do we get off
the rails
well we were asked i told you we were
asked to
implement a diagnostic test for folks
that
uh we thought had sars cov2
and so a diagnostic test is typically
used to confirm a specific diagnosis
someone has signs and symptoms of the
disease
and the the test is performed yes you're
right they do have group based drought
it goes along with their red throat and
fever
right they do have sardis kobe too it
matches their signs and symptoms
but then these tests the same tests that
were made to be diagnostic tests
were migrated to a screening test often
in rule of diagnosis right
we've got a healthy person coming in for
surgery
i'm not saying these are bad things i'm
just saying we gotta recognize the
limitations and i'll share those with
you in a minute
we have a healthy person coming in for
for surgery
we want to make sure they don't have a
brewing
uh an early uh sars cov2 infection
because
their outcome could be worse literature
on that so we're going to use this test
to rule it out
and so the issue with this is
the issue of false positives that we'll
discuss and you know so
for a for a highly sensitive screening
test
you want to capture everybody and then
you want to
uh differentiate true positives from
false positives
with a confirmatory test think about how
we uh screen
blood for um for
uh donation we'd rather have more
false positives and throw those units
away than
give someone hiv or hcv etc so you get
the idea
broad net with screening tests critical
background concepts we have to review
pre and post test probability uh
pre-test probability is really another
way of saying disease prevalence
so what is the likelihood that that that
patient has a particular disease before
the test is performed
i see a red throat i see a kid with a
fever i see spots on their tongue
pretty high likelihood they have group
based drought this translates to stars
kobe too
too right do they have the signs and
symptoms post test likelihood
what is the chance that they have that
disease after the test is performed
and importantly it's really the clinical
reliability or accuracy of
that one test for that one patient
and we'll see how that uh plays out in a
few minutes
so um three interesting concepts you may
not have thought
thought about since uh uh since school
but we're going to revisit them
bayes theorem likelihood ratio and
fagin's normogram and these
are going to come together in a perfect
storm to demonstrate
uh the importance of pre and post-test
probability
in test interpretation so bayes theorem
is really
a uh a probability
of an event based on prior knowledge of
conditions that relate to that
event what we talked about already right
pre-test probability does it look like
the person has that illness
then that's going to play into it then
you can use sensitivity and specificity
to calculate a thing called likelihood
ratio
and we'll do that as a part of an
exercise in just a couple minutes
and so a likelihood ratio greater than
one probability increases less than one
probability decreases
and then interesting tool called fagan's
normogram
published all the way back in 1975
that's going to bring all these together
so our transplant surgeons wanted me to
talk to them
about false positive tests and
they are we're using our rapid test our
uh expert um from cepheid and again i'm
reminding you of the sensitivity and
specificity
and so here we are able to calculate for
you a likelihood ratio so we've got a
high likelihood ratio
far above one of about 14 13.94
and so a pretty darn good test
now uh
in our in our pre-surgical asymptomatic
population
we were running a positivity rate of
uh 0.5 so about 1 in 200
uh patients that didn't look like they
had disease were positive
so we're just going to use that in our
calculation to demonstrate this
principle
so let's break out fagin's dormigram and
i'll walk you through this
so we're going to concentrate on the
red line first and so on the left hand
side
i've got the red line starting at a 50
probability 0.5 and so that is a patient
that
really looks like they probably have the
disease right now it could be something
else that's causing their cough and
fever
but we're in the middle of the pandemic
pretty high likelihood
so let's run that line through our
likelihood ratio
of 14 and we come up with a post-test
probability
of um you know 90s in in the 90
percentile i can't see it on this slide
the numbers are a little bit uh a little
bit small
but we got a great post-test probability
they look like they have disease
we've got a test with good test
performance characteristics likelihood
ratio
14 and we come out with a
positive predictive value a post-test
likelihood
in the 90s this is a you could take that
test to the bank
now same test nothing has changed
look at the black line let's look at our
pre-surgical patients with a
0.5 percent pre-test likelihood 0.5
prevalence of positivity now run it
through the same great
test with a likelihood ratio of
14 and you are going to come up with a
with a 7 post-test probability
so a very terrible post-test probability
all because the populations are
different
uh it's actually amazing how can a the
same task
perform so differently in different
populations
so absolutely key to understanding the
interpretation of the results
of of tests in a diagnostic setting
versus a screening setting so let's go
on and i pull a
chart for you out of the clsi document
gp49
and this just looks at the same thing
but what it's done
is the lady that presented this to us
put this
in for the calculations of a generic
test
that's 95 sensitive 95 specific
and look at what you have again at the
bottom of the screen
on the left if you take the prevalence
of disease that's 50
just like our in our example in in this
situation you've got a positive
predictive value of 95
you're only going to have five out of
100 tests that are false positives
take you take those you can take the
positives to the bank
drop this down to a one percent
prevalence
i.e an asymptomatic screening setting
your positive predictive value becomes
16 all the rest of those positives
are false positives so you can see
that false positives become the bane
of a screening program
so um to sum up some of the things we've
been talking about
here before we move on is test
performance characteristics the
sensitivity and specificity of an assay
are only half of the equation uh
prevalence of disease the pre-test
probability and the likelihood ratio
uh of the test as determined by
sensitivity and specificity
determine the post-test probability that
the test result is accurate for that
patient
the use of the same high-performing test
is different in a diagnostic versus a
screening setting
and from some of the earlier data we
demonstrated these late ct
values these low viral loads um
they could be one or two things they
could be very early in disease
or more often now they're part of this
long tail of convalescence
that is a positive test that's
clinically not
meaningful so let's shift gears a little
bit and talk about saliva talking about
pooling because we said we were going to
do that and
some folks are interested in that and so
why would you ever consider
saliva well a few reasons uh
lust provider patient interaction
protect potentially
less need for ppe use you're not having
to take a
um take a specimen from a squirming
patient
uh you don't have to make the patient
squirm as lost patient discomfort
and so the question is is saliva really
superior
to the nasopharyngeal suave as
demonstrated by some of the yale studies
and
is a little bit counter to what we've
always felt in
uh clinical microbiology with the
nasopharyngeal swab being the
being the diagnostic specimen of choice
for respiratory viruses so again the
yale study
got this started a very well done study
i give them a lot of credit they looked
at first morning salivas
in some patients with severe disease
they also looked at some other groups
that's a group i'm concentrating on here
and
as demonstrated in the in the images
they demonstrated a greater sensitivity
with saliva compared with nasopharyngeal
swabs
uh and in a higher viral load so
this was also demonstrated by kojima in
their study
and they broke it down a little bit in a
way that informed our study
and what they did was they looked at a
supervised
collection a nasopharyngeal swab arm and
an
unsupervised saliva collection when in
the unsupervised it's really
uh they were watching but they weren't
coaching supervised is really coached
and so the folks that were coached on
how to do it right they had the best
sensitivity
nasopharyngeal swab or next and the
unsupervised or uncoached
was last with regards to sensitivity and
they believed that was because the
patients
failed to elicit a cough which was part
of the directions
now not everyone has found these i i've
given you a couple
of references here for folks that did
not find
a saliva to be superior to
nasopharyngeal swabs and you can see the
sensitivities there
and they found that viral loads they and
some other authors found that viral
loads were lower
so again it's a it's an area where we're
still working out the details
and we decided to do a a study of our
own
and uh we don't we weren't just testing
first morning patients that didn't
really fit we're
we were interested in symptomatic
outpatients
and so we set it up for when they were
scheduled they'd give their saliva
specimen this of course was irb approved
we came up with this idea of enhanced
saliva so
kojima taught us the importance of the
cough and others have seen that too
we added a hard sniff or a snuff
to pull in any upper respiratory
secretions and then elicit a cough
complete the
specimen delivery with uh whatever
saliva you could
give us three mls and this was done
uh while they were waiting in line for
the nasopharyngeal swabs so specimen
collected
first for saliva and then afterwards for
the nasopharyngeal swab
we looked at 224 patients
we excluded eight and we described uh
why we actually described those this
patient paper was just
accepted in journal of clinical
microbiology so you can look at all the
details
but when we look at the 216 paired
specimens that
that remain 38 were positive by both
methods so
uh saliva and nasopharyngeal swab 100
positive predictive uh positive percent
agreement
and then 177 of 178 were dual negative
the one specimen that was nasopharyngeal
suave negative saliva positive
uh was indeed adjudicated to have sars
kobe 2 present
when we tested it on another platform so
um then we looked at the mean crossing
thresholds or cts again as a surrogate
for a viral load and
we did not find what yale found we found
what some of the other researchers found
we found that the viral load was lower
in saliva compared with nasopharyngeal
swabs
so our conclusion from this was that
saliva
is an acceptable qualitative specimen
for symptomatic patients who get the
same positive or negative result
but in our hands there was a lower viral
load in saliva so
i would worry a bit if i i move this
into the asymptomatic
group but i miss some of the lower viral
loads
the ones that may be clinically
significant early in disease
i don't mind missing the late ones that
are not clinically meaningful
so everyone in the pool or not let's not
get in this pool these are the pools
that are bad
loaded with people but the pools we're
talking about is can you combine
specimens
and test them all and if negative
uh report out the negative on everyone
and if positive you're gonna have to
deconstruct that pool
and find out who caused the positive and
we know there's a long history of pool
testing
in transfusion medicine and and the
lifeblood donation
and so those papers inform some of these
studies when we started this study it
was
a a 95 correlation
was needed between the the neater
undilute specimen with the pools
that subsequently uh has been been
relaxed a little bit
uh and it can go down to at least 80
percent
with some caveats maybe appropriate with
appropriate limitations added to the
intended use
that would mitigate the risk of false
negatives etcetera so you get the idea
so a little bit of hedging there
but somewhere between 80 and 95
needs to be a match we did this for a
while at the clinic we
we were able to do two to one and this
was really because of the allocations
of the rapid tests the cepheid test
we're trying to
stretch them to go further we were able
to get two to one to work
not three to one and
uh then uh we couldn't even get two to
one
to work at the regional hospitals using
the same platform
so we are not pooling right now but
i was approached by uh by the nba
who partially funded a uh who funded a
study
in conjunction with some donation of
materials from cepheid
to look at a 10 to 1 dilution and so
this was an interesting study that
is on my desk to get written up but i'll
share some of the data with you
we purposefully looked at specimens that
were either in the mid ct
range as defined here or in the late ct
range
and then diluted those ten to one and
retested them
same day and you can see that ten of the
ten pools were detected that were in the
mid ct
range only ones that were missed were we
missed three in the late ct
range so again is that clinically
relevant or not
probably is if it's early in disease it
probably is not
it is not if it's latent disease
convalescence
and so we have the opportunity to study
the
uh the ct change with a ten to one
dilution about four
cycles and again we talk about what's
the risk of missing
and that this uh all the data together
if you took
all 20 and you got 17 out of 20
gives you an 85 correlation so so not
terrible
um but that was our um our experience
with pooling again we're not pooling
right now but you can see both
advantages and disadvantages
so some pearls i'd like for you to take
home
is i know your test performance
characteristics you've gotta
know how prevalent the pre-test
probability affects the post-test
probability
really don't use serology for diagnosis
is not useful there
it's useful for public health
surveillance
saliva is a viable option for testing
symptomatic patients
um i i did not do any asymptomatic so
i'm not commenting on that
pooling will miss some individual low
viral load you have
have to do a risk benefit assessment if
these were folks that were coming
being admitted to the hospital i would
be worried about missing a low viral
load
if these are folks that are going to go
home with appropriate
guard rails put around that test result
telling them to
uh you know still isolate themselves and
use appropriate mitigation
precautions you know you probably could
live with uh
you know missing a low viral load there
and again any information come back
if you're or contact back if you
are more ill so in conclusion tests are
tools
tools need to be used correctly and you
can see by the
image on the top we don't use hammers
for screws and bolts and we don't use
wrenches
for nails so same story here tools have
to be you have to know how to use them
i know how to use your tests you got to
know how to use them correctly
which has to do with with the uh
prevalence of disease
and finally a you know a colleague of
mine
at university of north carolina said
this many many times i can't help but
pirate it
we can't test our way out of this again
test test our tools
use them in conjunction with all the
mitigation strategies that we need to be
doing
wearing a cloth mask appropriate social
distancing
appropriate hand hygiene etc and so
that's how we're going to get out of
this and
and we will get out of this so with that
i know you'll have the opportunity to
submit some questions i'm happy to
to respond to those and i thank you for
tuning in
to this presentation and niall roots for
giving me the opportunity to give it
thanks so much